well it's a Thursday I'm back from the
upfront I'm back from all of New York
I'm back from nollans where I was
spending my time with miss megan fox
Julia Jones Josh Duhamel in the road I
like to drop these names and Megan and
Megan Fox let's say twice yeah and then
I heard from Owen question canal from
Big Bang Theory oh wow my new favorite
person and then you went to New York
then I went to New York just he'll let
people know what the up fronts are up
front so where you go and you basically
announce your show and then you mingle
with all the buyers of advertisers all
of yes yes and all the buyers who are
fans of the Goldbergs and so it was it
was awesome now how do you suck off
everyone at their franchise that work
might is it only hand jobs or do you
offer your rump to or minami I'm
basically walking I go guys I got two
holes and don't lose hands go to waste I
got two holes and two hands and for you
big boy
I'll even use my feet that's right guys
don't have a lot to say right now I'm a
little tired from doing a movie but I
got two holes I got two holes and tan
and a positive attitude and I'll use my
feet if I have if I go limp just wake me
up by bust oh dude well they're gonna
see this and you're screwed corporate
now I am corporate now you're corporate
it was fun though it was fun yeah it's a
privilege I walk I find the other guard
before you've done this before I find
the red carpet very very awkward it's
hot it's the worst
the women doll up job over here smile
put a fist stop nope nope they split I
know nope no Facebook a walnut the
Golden Globes I can put a fist up and
zeros in yeah well you're good you you
doll up cuz you like fashion well you
check so you you big you're big man
check and I think like if did you look
like [ __ ] on the red carpet well hold on
stylist hold on I'll get normal to Vince
and I bought a black suit Oh Vince can
you get it soon I didn't I wasn't I
didn't look like a piece of coral it
wasn't tailing like a piece of fire
coral the way you do okay no you look
you know you look like an uber driver
dude I really resent Zach like an uber
girls wearing and a car who's this the
Brian town but I was like you know bird
driver I was
an expensive pair I was wearing an
expensive theory suit of course and I
got 13 what well you have these flutes
because you guys I got it at a sample
sale
oh no yeah I did that means once my
common projects you [ __ ]
no no there was a stain on the pants
there was a stain on the butt that black
suit no it was blue blue and the white
color in this shirt a black undershirt
not bad I pulled it off
and then I had a blue I had my slide
belt I put on my slide belt one of our
sponsors
oh nice and I put the one on his head
fire in the kid and then I had my common
projects I'm not mad that I was looking
adorable ladies - I'm not gonna lie to
you
I hope so really but they were talking
about the thing is some dudes bright hit
I need to though well no I had to stand
there have you ever been up front so
this I have signs nothing but you've
never been on your own spin off like you
never liked the lead I was on what on
inside Schwartz which was one and also
uh fat actress but this is a good but
that was one in a while but that wasn't
your show right I was I was a series
regular but this is a little different
yeah this is a bigger deal yeah I guess
it's based off your character it's all
the same though to be honest really yeah
you know it's still the same feel
validated they they know you from the
Goldbergs and you know but but again
this is my my quote-unquote success
celebrity whatever you want to call it
or whatever I have a celebrity by now
whatever you whatever I have of it where
you go right has been so gradual it's
been such a glacial pace and you know my
mother said my mother goes my mother's
so funny she goes well I'm a witch and I
go what she goes I'm a witch I had I had
wished this for you I didn't want you to
get really successful quickly I want it
to be a very slow gradual process so
that you so that you didn't explode
thank you mom I know thanks mom thank
you for not watching I was a child actor
thank you for so long
thank you for your hacks but yeah thanks
for nothing how about being famous when
I'm 30 when I when I got this dong out
oh my god how you survived that I've no
idea I wasn't famous people mess up what
had a lot of children yeah you see I'm
people met a lot of divorce there's no
how to channel drunk bro
right now I'm not a drug guy you'd be
surprised yeah yeah well stress
probably but New York how's New Orleans
house filming you haven't shot a moving
forever it's been a long time
nollans nollans is fun we're shooting in
New Orleans please say noms solids there
you go now did you see my boy ray rabies
the rat Maria yeah that's right that's
holy nutria rabies
that's home of the biggest rat in the
world yeah mr. rich from Africa mr. ray
rabies yeah well you used to yeah lotta
raise you see a lot of ray run around a
lot of rats money you need them in the
summertime not there in that when it
gets hot not the cleanest place in the
world no they're also the size of small
children yeah you need those things yeah
grill them up I like a little occasional
yeah I don't mind me there's a cute big
hands where did you shoot down there
he's like the heart of New Orleans in
the heart
I was really well you'll buy you stand
in the in the French Quarter stand in
the French Quarter good food mm-hmm not
good for my psoriasis a lot of creams
and sauces the old legs were like a man
the humidity can't be good for your skin
either well no that is good for my skin
oh really humidity is good for my skin
mood New Orleans but not the not the
amount of alcohol that they forced down
your throat and certainly not all the
creams you can't but you drink about
chuckle well it's just there man and I'm
watching jazz and they throw a beer in
my hand then a nice uh uh maybe a nice
absinthe
wow man now I'm a gentleman as you know
and sometimes you say Jesse up since
without a list I'm the only ninth and
then I'm and then I'm I'm with some
people and I'm like you know I've been
working all day I'm gonna have some
heads and eat tails I'm gonna have a you
mean crawfish yeah would ya tink I'm
gonna suck some head and we shut down
the heads and eat yeah else
so then you got your cross sock cats and
he tails I'm gonna keep saying that you
got your crawfish
yeah and then do you wait at night did
you suck heads smash some tails
you got your crawfish yeah out so I'm
referring to do you have a bunch of
drinks and suck suck the heads I had
some crawfish yeah I know you keep
selling that but I'd like to know more
about this crawfish
I had some drinks and then I legs were
like ever I give you one more drink and
then tomorrow I'm gonna blow up like on
you like a balloon I was like one more
drink I'll be sucking these these heads
I'm sauce on them all right I don't know
what you're talking about but here's the
bottom line my legs look like I look
like a red leopard by the hole you broke
out bad it looked like a red leopard
down or yet pants I danced huh
I had pants on did you miss the movie
set uh you know being an actor is uh
there's a lot of waiting around as you
know so you better like the people
you're working with and I do like the
people I'm working with so you can joke
around yeah but you know it's well but
please man I kind of don't let's
understand we're shooting with dogs and
with kids yeah now dogs and kids will
take your schedule and they'll make a
mockery of it well those kids getting
need a couple takes the dogs ain't gonna
get it right kids they're also gonna
need time off after eight hours if they
should know they can only go for two
right well they have to go they do then
you got homeschooling correct and you
got school yeah the kid laws on acting
is crazy thanks Lindsay yeah and you
gotta shoot me right we got a whole
nother scene thanks Doogie Howser we got
a little ooh Twitter we got a shoot
things on Fred Savage and they go they
go
thanks Oracle and then they go
thanks blossom and then they go thanks
Olsen twins got a half hour we're gonna
lose these kids you got saints Cosby
kids but I got two more seems to do we
gotta lose kids and then 150 kids file
out on the dot on time and you're left
holding the bag then you gotta shoot
with dogs and sometimes dog goes you
know what I'm gonna shoot the dogs I'm
Doug Doug goes you know I feel like
[ __ ] on set well I got a story about
that Oh what happened I got a story
about that a lot of times more likely as
dog goes what are you gonna do get in my
face no you're not gonna do that I'm
gonna run away from you I'm a snarl like
I'm gonna bite your lip something and
also you know you're not hugging me you
know I know you're supposed to hug me
and I'm supposed to be excited you have
your arms around me don't know you so
I'm gonna run away I got a dog with it
and you're standing there
your feet have to be in the shot just
your feet have to be in the shot that's
reacting she'll stand there for a good
hour and a half sir to get this shot so
that dog and you're like you [ __ ] by
the end you're like willing that dog you
want to kill that day you know so that
Taylor then the kid gets frustrated and
the trainer goes listen he can sense
your frustration oh my and the kids a
kid the kids 10 the kids like kid
doesn't care the dog doesn't let me hug
you know it's it's it's all that and
they do they all pull it off though at
the end of the day old Ranger stuff they
all pull it off and I do it it's amazing
but I Anna did I ever tell you the story
about when I had to shoot with a goat no
worried you want to go I all I had to do
is show up in Ventura farms a goat and I
had to morph into from a goat to a
person from to a person who goes so they
take you they shoot you just stand there
shoot you takes 1 2 3 4 then take the
goat shoot to go 1 2 3 4 little movie
was this and then done that's all I had
to do for the day I was doing MADtv no
gotcha I had a whole schedule I was
going hiking with a young lady young
Tommy dick well hash tag young as tag
grateful
hashtag Los Angeles hashtag on TV
hashtag first time that's tagged rotten
did a sad kid in a candy store
okay hashtag no condoms ever hashtag
loads has that roll the dice that steak
still had crooked teeth hashtag not as
crooked because it took a long time
Esther had here back the hashtag
Invisalign is not working and hashtag
hashtag I [ __ ] told you get metal
breaks a second Hank Brennan is always
right how's that gonna bully my dentist
need you there to shove him around okay
deal
okay so goat got it shoot me then they
bring the goat in shoot the goat goat
won't stand still and the ghosts making
noise no circling and sitting down and
they're like what's this coat to him
thought this coat was training it is
trying I don't know what's going on
goats circling sitting down making noise
they try to hold the goat the goat
sits down again the goal won't stand up
it stands up again God turns around the
goat decides I look at it I got back
something's going on with that goats ah
there's the [ __ ]
it was puckering like this yeah it was
blowing kisses yeah problem was it
wasn't just its [ __ ] the coat had a
baby right there oh well right there
hey goat trainer don't bring the
pregnant one to set yeah more about not
breaking me [ __ ] goat you have you
have a hundred you brought the one
that's gonna have a baby on set the goat
had the baby
yeah one's right there the guard had the
baby right there now the makeup girls
are crying says their emotional is so
beautiful
really yeah oh I'm gonna set that looks
like a tender lamb 105 let's veal I'll
bring it over to Via Veneto we got to
probably two in the house right now
so so that's fine okay but now we still
gotta get the shot this is Hollywood
show must go on right so they decide all
right God had the baby let's just take
the baby and put it over there for a
second doesn't work shoe on the mom baby
your mom starts going like where the
[ __ ] is my baby
where's my baby and the baby's like hey
hey now all the makeup girls like how
dare you it's a mother she has to feed
that baby and they're right all right
and so it's not gonna work as the
mothers a hysterical the baby's crying
everybody's up in arms not me I want to
get laid so if the baby's got to go
without Mama's teed for a couple [ __ ]
we are in this up that's how it is
you're a bad person but yes also like
goat put it in that [ __ ] place and
shoot nope can't do it so real [ __ ] Club
oh my god damn it yes
don't do it all right so they let the
baby and the mother together all right
fine that crying okay you got it they
bring another goat in that takes about
an hour and a half two hours go don't go
chose up I'm not kidding
we're in the hills of Ventura that goat
hit the ground it hit the ground and it
friend okay I mean I mean it's the top
speed into the hills I've never I
couldn't [ __ ] believe how fat I was
like what
like I say they go running after him I
never forgot the trails go what the [ __ ]
and then in error and the crew and they
go running after it they can't find the
goat so now they had a search party for
the PS hashtag never found the goat hash
that coyote food that night one harm out
mine was like please well I saw that
night I saw a [ __ ] a bobcat game oh
so there's no doubt that it Bobcat
coyotes or a mountain lion got that
there's milk in the real world be able
code can't be a goat in the hills of
California believe it or not cuz you're
going that's bad idea not lasting yay
lasting the night
there's mount lines all over those
places on lines all over the mountains
all over yeah they get another we shoot
it and what was that long because by the
time I got out of there it was about I
don't know 10 at night they go p-- hate
it on your dick game so now I eat goat
just just when I can just respond you
order it no fact I order it and I don't
eat it I waste it mmm I believe in
poaching goats when do you uh so now
when do you start shooting the Goldbergs
but stuff the end of August it's going
down and all you see if some time yeah
three weeks on one week off pretty cool
it's not bad no then you shoot every
Monday through Friday yeah so I'm
shooting not shooting just before you
shot uh you know how it is yeah why not
I've never been on this that comment but
you're doing below the belt so yeah yeah
thought of work yeah so but it's such a
well-run machine and it's all people
like no I found out the Goldbergs isn't
syndication Oh times place six times a
day all over the world I was just told
on TV is told what kind of money I'll be
making it was you happy nice little
conversation
well then I'm seeing a high percent of
the show from Illinois hashtag never
enough money hashtag the more you make
the more he spent he was saying how
steady though sorry please
Shannon if I had that kind of hair I'd
never keep it covered but he always
covers a lot Cinzia yeah
chin i swirly I'm not trying to be
racist at all but can agent people have
curly hair I'd usually straight curly
but wavy it's usually pretty straight
though I've never seen like curls yeah I
don't think they actually have
in Japan where the Yakuza in Shinjuku
where they Shinjuku you know where isn't
yuku even their fairy tale that doesn't
matter anyways they the guys perm their
hair the gangsters will permit yeah but
I'm saying that with a lot of them are
born that way no one's born I don't
really hear I think for the most part is
just straight like because I got African
eggs are born with straight here you're
not born with blonde hair
African Americans not to be racist are
generally not born with really long
blonde hair yeah but that's that's all
got yeah dime she's also got some black
in it she looks like she's missing yeah
she don't got some black and there's not
by the way I'm a big fan of that mix I'm
a big fan of Asian black Asian white I
like anything I like that mix anything
Asian mix is so like that yes
don't ever show me that go to the Jaypee
again that's some of the most beautiful
that you know I agree it is yeah I wish
I was a little more exotic looking I
know I was your agent man the girl from
chain what's that show chain um she's in
that show it's on The WB right yeah she
W she was easy she was a play on me
she's WB ain't a very beautiful W or CW
is it still CW you see a woman like that
in real life when she's just hang which
one chain the version to star that she's
gorgeous we talked about her boyfriend
and her boyfriend is more gorgeous I was
staring at her boyfriend more than I was
staring at her like a man but that's
whatever both both both could look in
people Jesus is she Asian Gina Rogers
just Mexican right or Spanish
you should she dude with other Asians
well of cool okay Gina Rodriguez of
course my my one of most famous women in
the world she is is she's very faint I
didn't know that she's very gorgeous or
really cool I don't know what do I know
this what happens near your Hollywood
shill I know turn boring and now man oh
did you see her on a plane this
beautiful woman yeah and see about our
boyfriend might be more beautiful can
you sit that bro great Bobby alright
great hair full mouth boyfriend Joe yeah
let's take a look at him all right there
there
handsome yeah he's all right I don't
like his hair like that I call him Jim
bring up another picture I call it a
chin oh yeah he's just a great he's just
a guy look at him there nice all right
man dude you got it baby who's on the
plane very impressed looks good and
sweat I found myself going I want to
look like him wonder if he was an
athlete or something there he is there
he is
got some muscles on him too I call him
average Joe oh you should I come from
calm average oh I don't know
Denver Colorado would call that an
average man don't call him that because
you don't know set of teeth on them you
didn't see he's got a full mouth and
he's got greats gonna tell you sales
cars they're gonna like look man I don't
don't like you sells kids don't belittle
my boyfriend I'm impressed
are you glad to be back in LA yes yes I
love Angelina you what I had a nice
breakfast more Natalie knows God they
make the best breakfast breakfast in the
world the hands down best they're soft
scramble thank you though the German I
was eatin with Hans woohoo I hunt that
monster goes soft is it like Ronnie and
she goes no it's out Ronnie I went it's
exactly what is it soft scrambled don't
talk about restaurants around fabbrizio
because he uh they don't have a
breakfast spot how come you don't guys
don't have a breakfast oh it doesn't
matter
all right I'm cool some of the best
breakfast that's been that's the best
kept secret in LA Julian that's never
busy
did you have the 9 grand pancake of
course damn right you did that's just
yeah and then they're vacant and then
the the sock scramble it is soft my
mouth is watering now you got to start
my mouth is watering
it's not a lot of food is it though uh
they're not giving it away but you can
eat I'm saying it's not a lot of food
though like this small serving not for a
big boy like you but it's fine for my
tiny Tommy yeah time fine for me
I'm 170 or 270 you see our boys out in
uh oh say speaking of what you had your
boy Matrona right well the belt comes
out next week knows an on so I'm out in
New York your boy Jimmy Burke and sorry
enough I saw darlin
Dov is awesome I'm still doing a text
and up coming back on crashing this
season I was great on that
yeah he's killing it in the stand up
game he's still doing a ton of stand up
yeah
does the reason the New York sloppy
stuff he's killing it he's never comes
la anyone yeah
he's in the real estate he's in the
business acting stuff it's all he's into
all of it we had a good time I'm gonna
laughs do you guys eat at that
Mediterranean restaurant no my favorite
restaurant no we had a camp gamma but uh
that there's something I don't know if I
enjoy anything more than a meal and a
good sign no I wasn't gonna say that I
said have you've changed bro yeah hold
on you're just different conversation
yeah I guess a little boring I've gotten
your more I [ __ ] podcast going
searching for something I told you a
story that went nowhere before we
started the one of the war stories over
in my life and he gave us a four-hour
long goat story that's how long ago
story and then now you're talking about
I just like a nice meal and a
conversation yeah and then I say dick
sucked and you look at me like I'm some
eye cream I'm like really like how do
you sir I'm on ABC now Oh Mike Oh would
they ever say anything [ __ ] what I
don't know but I'll come back to the
podcast and you stand up how about I
disagree you know what I guarantee if
they're like Brian we need you stop
talking about sucking dick right right
your jig gnarled up eared friend okay we
need you to stop you come on like bro
listen I'm not telling you how to talk
could not reach dicks anymore on the
show it would help me out a lot
yeah can you imagine no thanks I'll just
cut the nice thing about not being just
an actor is I'll come back to my podcast
and I'll do stand-up thank you by the
way everybody for ice we sold out tire
Hall in two days I can't believe that
dang a third show welcome don't I'm not
- I'm not doing three shows we're pretty
no I don't know hey don't I'm not doing
three first to me listen I don't know no
no no show Thursday I do oh ok 3 the day
I've done oh oh dude I don't we don't do
I thought we were talking to that okay
down
without for the [ __ ] I shouldn't have
let you do that nope you [ __ ] me but
you had lost my voice yet alarm cuz
you're an athlete so you would have
fought you would have forced yourself
lost your voice mm-hmm
lost your voice that's uh people don't
realize that that's over three hours of
comedy in one night not easy and you're
shouting and they don't agree yeah and
meet-and-greets says another hour
about six hours that's a barreled laughs
you're moving that big body around which
breaks down dude I was at the Comedy
Store on Tuesday night and Dane Cook
went on before me and just a crowd work
and these girls were heckling him and he
goes if you've gone I get I usually in
the middle of story goes you [ __ ] up
the story so I can keep going or I can
go on you say another thing I'm going
you know I'm trying to be cool and she
goes bring it and he just [ __ ]
unleash the fury I was laughing my ass
off so bad he's been doing it too long
oh dude you don't get in a ring with a
guy like that [ __ ] piece you areas huh
it was great but dum-dum is in the
audience know nothing about you know I
have a very it's very hard to make me
mad yeah nothing makes me angrier I
don't know why nothing
nothing irritates me more not angry
irritates me over then then hot girls in
an audience who are entitled and talking
that was there be these course it was
yeah of course
bachelor party ha yeah hot girls
bachelor parties nah not allowed on my
show not not in front row I think Dan
was doing some new material so he's like
telling a story you tell it was it like
that cleaned up and he's like in there
some last and then they go he's like
funk and go on with the story when you
do this and she was praying it oh my god
what'd he say oh my god he said you look
like a stripper I'd take home from the
club and then when he gets in my house
the lights when I go wow and then he
just kept going you kikyo's every time
[ __ ] look over you got less and less
clothes on I look over your tits around
your tits right you know you just kept
breaking down a thing and just kept
going fantastic was nothing no they
liked it
a girl like it like they want to be
attention the other girl like that I was
on a date with a girl in New York when I
was I don't even think I started doing
stand-up I'm she was a hot girl in my
acting school
and went crazy but before she went crazy
she was so painfully hot came from very
wealthy family and we were on a date I
was like oh [ __ ] she likes me I forgot
and by the way
now it's y'all I'm going through a
fantasy of like she was from another
country and I'm like again maybe out of
yeah I'll be married I'll fly around on
private jets and I'll be like kind of an
aristocrat I'd be a general drink one
gentleman drink wine do anal all that
stuff I'm on ABC dude I can't talk about
anal I'm trying to sabotage your show
okay
oh my god that's what you're trying to
do dude you're you're quietly trying to
sabotage my show you're trying to get me
fired dude you're not speak we do it all
you fires I know
show times like one well at least
Showtime is dirty you can speed it up
jiggle is on there hey how about you
know you know when you're getting a
little too comfortable I'm gonna take
said with like the higher is up is short
time I go how about gigolos let's bring
that back nothing nothing not a wink you
go no one's responding back to me
we're like in the middle having fun I
love that movie did the show jigglers
forever seen it they follow six male
escorts in Las Vegas and just shows them
[ __ ] doing stuff all literally my
favorite show of all time and when I was
when I first moved to LA I saw one of
the guy then walking with his family
he's pushing stroller
no.1 they're not famous and I recommend
guys just watching that before I go then
bro give it up and he was like did how
they like was like not happy about it I
was so ashamed
so then I'm going back for throw time
text I know
gigolos bring it back in my right
crickets I did I made the same mistake
Scott Harris who owns innovative I don't
know him but he's the owner of the
company and also and my agent and then
some other agents and also some of the
other people that were invited this
dinner we're all on the same email
thread and they said Scott meet Brian
Brian meet Scott owner of innovative
he'd like to host you guys for dinner
in New Orleans and stuff at NOAA and
just me and I go and they thanks nice to
meet you Brian a very
and I go I'll show you the email I go I
should enjoy steal a line I steal a line
that I heard I think was on on the goods
that movie I did and I go bring your
boner pants because you will have a
boner by the time I'm done I was like I
kept checking my email like come on
somebody the next day Scott goes I'll
bring my boner pants I was like okay you
don't know we joke around like don't
worry about riches [ __ ] or you know like
you don't even really know Christy later
that I did that on Sunset or I also did
it with the lady with doing the clear
thing she is it's gonna be it's me
seventy something dollars
and she's like you're swinging the price
to me and I'm like in a rush but I'm you
know I'm he's talking like we're talking
about you doesn't matter I'm rich as
[ __ ] let's just do it she goes oh wow
alright okay I'm like no but I was
kidding I mean like that oh my god yeah
you don't know me at all and I just said
that that sounds so bad that can get me
so rich as [ __ ] so you get your poor
hands and kisses no I'm just kidding I'm
just gonna I'm looking at this picture
of the gigolos it's the best it's not
the greatest things I've ever seen
yeah for it's a nightmare the greatest
dudes of all time but it does not end
well for him the guy in the middle and
the with the v-neck the ball gentleman
is VIN who I ran into and he was
hilarious is he a good guy I have no
idea I just know he ditched girls down
he sure does and he considered himself a
real feminist well of course it says
dude the dude over there with the shirt
up that with his terrible body and the
white hair dude he's the old one he's
awful you know he's you would love him
he's older and he's trying to contend
with young guys oh he's so hilarious
really I want to see this
now Allah loves I love the Native
Americans / Spanish dancer oh he follows
me on Twitter I forget his name he does
Jiu Jitsu he's kind of legitimate is he
yeah like winds a tie BJJ [ __ ] yeah
really but he also will [ __ ] your girl
he's yeah he's fantastic
dude you know I was I couldn't be a jig
lad watch a show I still watch reruns
like
a week I'm weirdo um but yeah I'll watch
them but I couldn't I could not do the
job cuz I'm so visual they'll show up
and it won't that guy's the best-looking
one he's bit of a tool we've got five
hair did you see his body you know
that's not the juice guy just a guy go
see the top right picture that's he's
also a rapper yes
eunuch [ __ ] rapping dude he's great the
tat I'm just introducing this world
Brian you're welcome oh man I'm [ __ ]
I'm in Nick Hawk of course his name is
Nick Hawk official video right there bro
these guys are the best
and you're the best
he's doing jiu-jitsu he knows it he's
won he's won some tournaments this is
the guys with yeah legit I mean the
fireman's carry
enos digit so he's like what one ibj
like legit all right yeah no but doesn't
mean he's a good rapper entertainer but
it means he's awesome
oh you just stabbed that guy lady
stabbed like guys for the backpack oh
he's a bullying did you took all his
books away
[Music]
this is the worst video of all not when
I say of all time I mean Frank of all
time when they're going through the
editing process and they're watching
this like oh my god it's not good you
know what you know what it makes me
think you realize how legit real rappers
are and sometimes you don't know this
and and why you know I don't know I'm a
fan but goddamn that's tough
it's just tough he's a he's a beginner
right well no at rapping and help nope
nope because go to Michael reports
Instagram for me this kids 14 and so
that would be a beginner let me show you
beginning but you know what the problem
is there's also something called talents
and there's God giving gifts and she
said you didn't [ __ ] know he's just
think the [ __ ] probably okay she's
just not paying the bills so so go down
to the middle one that second row middle
one
it's kids 14 so you just said he's a
beginner yeah this gets 14 so sure he
looks like my younger brother but
whatever oh no it's not fire but you
ready you cannot you're out
[Music]
it's 14 I'd be a beginner that's the
time
can you see so you can't go oh he's just
a beginner we go there's talent that's
called the difference just some people
are made to do things some are it's
called the different that's called a
difference Lodi well he's got how many
he's got 20,000 followers little dak
Danny James 13 year old so he's 13 or to
apologize he boney Island damn good
stuff man
today let me see another one don't say
stuff Jen I said good stuff
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's legit he's you know you know what
I'm thinking is just a beginner but you
know I'm thinking that that kids so good
that when he's established in 30 he's
gonna look back and go
he's not gonna cringe he's gonna look
back at 13 and go that's pretty good
like that that's if I saw the [ __ ] I was
doing at 13 oh I'm sorry if I said I was
doing it 20 and myself [ __ ] I was
writing and performing at 25 muscles
years I would [ __ ] cringe I'd be like
oh my god and this kid is 13 and he's
gonna look back and go you know what
that's pretty good you know what I I
kind of like I kind of why he works
right now will you ever seen you ever
seeing Justin Bieber 13 that's all you
had discovered he's playing the drums
and singing he's an usher went oh he's
pretending yeah
those freaks up there man yeah oh and
they they what they've been doing uh
since there were three maybe I don't
know if he's rapping at three but maybe
well there's that little asian girl I
forget her name which you talked about
the one that's little Thai Ngoc devoted
a little Taytay that's just weird
well we're kind of Forster called talent
I Karen when Gretzky was when he was two
and they would turn the hockey game when
he'd watch hockey he'd be like this at
two his mother would put it on cuz he
wouldn't do anything but stare at it so
she wanted to keep him occupied he'd be
like this hmm
and he could watch hockey all day at
2:00 and when they would turn it off
he'd start crying
that was it too so whatever is going on
in his brain the geometry of hockey was
something he was obsessed with did his
dad play hockey
I don't think they see a lot of that
because epigenetics like well yeah
because what my son was boxing glued to
it
glue [ __ ] glued to it real but I
remember I don't want being a fighter
shuttle and watch it but if even if I'm
flipping through he they don't know I'll
stop when alone no [ __ ]
and he's also he's also a big and strong
and I told you what I noticed about him
you throw a ball at that kid's face
every kid will turn my kid turns that
kid eyes wide open takes it right in his
face right in the FATA full-bore I mean
and the ball wasn't that soft the ball
was kind of like a it was nerfed with
plastic around it so he just got dead
like that I went here comes the cry here
comes tears he goes hmm I was like oh
he's not his hands are a little bigger
than yours yes they're a little bigger
and his wrists are a little thicker than
my anguish troubleman yeah yes we didn't
go down that room built for war ain't
that ain't that the way it is though
right you don't want him to do it I love
to watch boxing and Muse boxing dancing
is his thing like we were on Third
Street and there break dancers there and
he was obsessed with these break dancing
oh yeah it's cool all right man they're
here every week let's get out of here
and he just kept one to watch and I see
they wrapped it I'm like what's over I'm
all done he's like right then he goes
home what's he doing get something he's
get on the ground go like this and turn
in doing wow like Jesus Christ Wow
I know let's for sure not be a
breakdancer though cuz I want you to
live with me too you're 40 let's not be
breakdance oh that's gonna be the
problem oh great that's the promise
they're doing a whole new [ __ ] show
on step-up you I don't want you being a
break heads and we'll test you because
you wanted to be one thing and then
they're not I don't want to be anything
I just I don't I don't what I don't want
is the fight life form okay I want that
form that's that I understand I
understand this list you only it's like
a talent singing or some she'll be cool
all these like a big-ass Enrique
Iglesias
Oh of all the girls I've loved before I
want to dedicate this to my father he's
going to have an accent because all he
speaks his Spanish at home he only
understands Spanish and it makes it very
difficult because when you're two you
mix words and when they're mixed in
Spanish the communication between me and
him is there
I want to dedicate this to my father the
big old guy over there with the gray
hair who's broken down because of all
the sports the gringo bah
Thank You me not Balki Ringo pop again
we'll thank you so much and this is
things in Spanish did she score my
father remember me remember me I wish I
could speak spandex again son your
Mexican son of lamech will you tell me
he texts me and you go well my house is
Mexico coz Oh everybody's speaking
Spanish because my my wife my me my girl
my girls mother my son everybody
speaking that and my girls my girls moms
mom his great grandma everybody speaking
and now when I see Spanish I mean for
her grandma you know it's not even fair
to say English is their second language
shouldn't speak Mandarin - it shouldn't
speak a lick of English you don't
understand it either
yeah so it's all Spanish all the time
very tough you know the TV I have to
read subtitles waltz in Spanish have you
thought about learning Spanish I'm I'm
just consumed with I'm around I pick up
the little things but you're not gonna
it doesn't work like I just say shoes in
Spanish shoes yeah so pot those hey go
to base its day I'm definitely more
Mexicans applause definitely will make
my heart's Mexican that's why there's no
quitting me when I box yeah whatever you
get some kind of instant I'm saying
whatever cold chin what you been up to
man we've been doing a lot of work I've
worked every day this you've been doing
a lot of work for sure yeah but you've
been involved imma be here yeah not too
much except on Tuesday yeah I didn't I
wasn't with you on Tuesday we should we
shot I shot this Deadpool
scene for below the belt cuz the new
Deadpool's coming out yeah so we did a
fake audition for it and they got me
like a Deadpool costume dick was hanging
out the front man thank you
can we do something about them - no too
tight if snug all people talk about is
Conor McGregor's dick on the set of my
nobody watches MMA but they all know
about Conor McGregor's dick the only
kids took your picture and you just
hands just all talking about his giant
dick it's hilarious I know they don't
watch anime but they know him right
there you go
especially the ladies well they're all
having a conversation about oh they love
them - giant deck
Wow yeah oh my god did my podcast there
like he did really yeah I loved you I
tell you he's been killing on podcast
like there's Marc Maron
he had Josh Brolin on there [ __ ] I'm so
good he's so yeah he's one of my
favorite actors but with marki name it
was so [ __ ] good why what were they
talking about I'm always worried of
acting actors because I don't know what
to ask them I know but with with Marc
Maron he because he's had like he had a
Sean Penn on and Sean Penn was like
playing like didn't want talked about
acting one get anything who's promoting
something so it's not of fun interviews
being an actor like we've had guys in
here with her actors but Josh Brolin was
just opened up about everything is his
drug abuse and being sober why he chose
do the movies he did because his dad was
an actor yeah how that kind of and he's
saying how that kind of hurt his career
at first and then he was talking about
how he got into acting how he's so like
didn't want to do it because his father
and then yeah he's talking about his
drug use and how he was an addict sober
and then mark goes see this is
conversation won't have a Sean Penn he
was but he just never let his guard down
and Josh goes well for me when I was
coming here obviously we're doing this
in your house he goes I didn't want to
like view this is like another
promotional thing I want to views as
like I take a piss I stopped in your
house you have been asked to have a
conversation with me and I had no agenda
that's and that's exactly what he did
and it's so so refreshing so good my so
refreshing because when you do a talk
show you can't do any of that those
aren't real it's all about promoting but
it but then Mayor also goes do don't you
feel like you know doing doing those
those movies like he's you know he's in
Deadpool and he's in Avengers 2 biggest
movies of the year and he's obviously
making [ __ ] tons of money who's do
you feel like you're selling out like
those movies aren't fun to do and Josh
Brolin goes do I turned him down for
years they've asked for him to me
forever and then I actually read the
script of Avengers and was I : I can be
the guy that like I'm not like this
gimmick I'm the guy who destroys all
them and he goes and then I did like
some pre-reading for it and I just
thought was a mistake and then the more
we did he's like and I love it now he
talks about how he didn't want to do it
it's cool [ __ ] man it's really cool how
about rolling that [ __ ] uh tyronn
yeah I'm starting broken last night cuz
he's a nicest guy
that's awesome I love that [ __ ] yeah
there's some I'd love to talk to Stevens
how those guys have lived a law of life
of show business I haven't listened to
it with Rogan Yvonne Shakespearian he's
one of the great frontman oh my god well
time and by the way one of the most
unique voices ever ever I Pitkin seize
that stuff I mean you know yeah that's
right now he's in crazy shape and I got
him Mick Jagger canoeist make Jagger's
in insane he's an Olympic shape then
they say it works out like he runs like
crazy miles every day yeah I'm times you
just got like sober at 60 cells really
it's gonna talk really talk yeah
sober at 60 yeah but he's like 17 hours
over like 19 years I had a fun
experience with Josh Duhamel who's such
a such a good guy
but josh has been working straight for
25 years and been pretty famous for a
long time but it's also six five and and
super handsome and what was funny is
that for whatever reason I'm with Kunal
from Big Bang Theory and you know I
don't know if you know about Big Bang
Theory but they make about 28 grand a
year
twenty-eight million dollars they're the
highest paid TV actors something yeah
right they make that perhaps so I'm sure
some crazy like technically an episode
but but and then and so people know who
you are because you've been on that show
for 12 years 12 years all right and
great [ __ ] guy by the way
such a nice person I can't take it and
funny and awesome and everything and
every way and then there is Josh and so
for whatever reason cuz josh is wearing
a hat I'm getting recognized from
fighter and kid dudes walk by I love you
love you bro so I'm looking at Josh and
I'm going oh good oh I'm going sorry
guys get recognized you know me I'm like
and then Josh josh is like oh cool
and then I'm going on sorry man yeah I'm
just celebrity I had to stop and talk to
a guy and they just keep walking and
then we go to Frenchmen Street and the
people the girls seep Josh they know
that at em game over yet skim over know
it's game illegal it merited forget for
13 years still I think they're very
still very good friend yeah so but the
ICC's I don't you know I hidden but but
the amount of attention no and he would
just he started
getting he started getting hit up by
girls and he was just he look at me and
quietly he's so nice he's like oh thank
you so much he go
he'd go he was like it's 2 to 1 Jesus oh
yeah you have no idea and then and that
he'd she could get recognized honey he's
gone that's four to one he's six five
yeah
he's every bit of six five like I played
quarterback in college we're out at D to
school k-member oh and but oh that's
right he's with Fergie first yeah but
probably the nicest guy in the world
well you said the other guy said nice
guy in the world so which one is it also
nice guys in the world I know but you
but will you have to pick one though cuz
you're sucking both of them up we got a
big one I am I am but well Josh isn't my
boyfriend obviously he's a good-looking
dude yeah he has been acting but that
but I was thinking but that kind of like
celebrity were you you're you're just
always getting people want to take
pictures always want to talk to you
that's that kind of [ __ ] and then you
take it out like Steven Tyler will you
take a guy I'm sure like Brolin who's
like in the zeitgeist it's gotta be I
don't know where you go I don't know
what you do I don't know where you go if
you're Stephen teller you're not going
to a jazz club in New Orleans you're not
doing it cuz you're not you're just not
going to get a chance to watch the music
it's and now everybody wants a picture
because they have their phones and stuff
it's just a constant constant which of
course is you learn how to navigate but
wow Steven Tyler can't hide it himself
yeah yeah I feel like if Josh dresses
right you could behind a blend and
they'll be alright you know sort of but
he's so tall I mean it's the crop I mean
you're that tall you people see you so
when you're the toast grind the little
tough cuz what's the what's he done if
it's a little different if you're like
Ryan Reynolds yeah my Rose was driving
down so I was driving a guy I'll Drive
down Olympia Saul Ryan Reynolds and it's
just like it's one of those like he's
not gonna blend in no I think what Josh
though what happens is because he's such
a handsome guy you look at the guy and
you guys go somewhere and yeah but he
was on he's been on he's gone from TV
show to TV show so people who are fans
of like Vegas and fans of the you know
the last show we did you know it's it's
just mm-hmm
but it's it's he's strikingly handsome
yeah yeah just dealing with that energy
all the day all day
informers that's right he's in
transformers yeah that's right handsome
dude uh youth intervention I do the
first one is actually kind of gross but
it's everywhere it's another kid dying
I'm not around nothing like that's gross
it's super gross I'm sure you guys heard
about this by now oh well no this was
incredible I haven't seen this was in
this is this is that a Tim Horton's
this is so impressive though yeah see
how quickly what happens so she's
obviously having a some sort of an
argument with the cashier probably cuz
their coffee sucks well there's a sort
of a backstory to this but I'll let you
watch first of all so she has a little
organic here but there's no that's
there's no volume that's what sucks
about it so we'll just you know you
could tell she's arguing with the person
that wasn't one all men
I need stronger coffee you guys hear me
this iced tea yeah it's too weak [ __ ]
your light roast
I need a darker roast give me my darker
roast he doesn't have a dark roast
really you don't have a dark she's
asking he's a restroom and they wouldn't
let her in so what does she do is well
I'm gonna go right here
yeah then do it man ready ready oh oh oh
what what a game she's gotta be anxious
what a gang she's gotta be a [ __ ] now
what would classy ladies old wife sends
well but laughter hand but she grabbed
the turd with her bare hands food at the
man but it looked like the term was very
hard because she there's nothing there's
no mark on the ground also if it's a
[ __ ] that hard she's side on that
[ __ ] thing like a pitch first of all
that turd that she's thrilled
that's gone look and why not pull your
pants up oh this was a dude look at how
far you came out that's the worst day of
work I quit I'm [ __ ] out why some way
took a [ __ ] on the floor man and food
hanging out fast she's got to be at jobs
you know what I don't think she's junky
regular lady no she's not a regular lady
the reason why they didn't let her in
the restroom because they let people in
the restroom even if you're not lying
she's a meth head yeah she she she
seemed like she was weird from before
yeah she's troublesome this another
thing I don't know how about you had to
take a [ __ ] because solid turds don't
explode out your ass
that came that well that note that thing
and also a solid turd like you can hold
that in yeah now if we came out like a
rocket ship I'm like I understand that
I've [ __ ] my pants in my car like that
you can't control that you're a normal
young lady and they wouldn't let you use
the bathroom and their coffee sucks yeah
I support that explosive diarrhea theory
there but that hard turd you get held
longer that came out I know she's crazy
that came out angry and and and in one
intact now what's what did it sound like
be honest
don't overdo it what are you sound like
when it hit the floor no what do you
think you let you team with stop nope
I think again no no it sounds like this
no disgusting I think what I think my
everything went like this I swear to God
oh did she get arrested or what happens
there yeah she's losing in life so we
put her in jail it's kind of an extended
to stay so I don't know you do have you
thrown your poet people we have to put
you in the zoo sir I think they I think
I think that guy needs a bonus of some
sort here's the here's the thing why are
you quitting you serious she's maybe
seven dollars an hour and I've been so
what do [ __ ] at my face man I got hit by
[ __ ] I hit by [ __ ] I hit by a [ __ ]
missile and now I would put her in the
monkey cage at the zoo for a while
because that's what it's like here like
many people miss he's obviously not all
there things aren't going well for a
killer understand the features freaking
out you're about to shoot your pants
guys like ain't happening lady not on my
watch like let me use the bathroom I've
had a bunch of MCT oil I've had a double
[ __ ] coffee espresso I've been nice
like you
put your pants you wouldn't poo the
floor not me you wouldn't you wouldn't
see I wouldn't do that to Starbucks or
Phil's Hortons weak coffee I'm [ __ ]
the floor I think she's a coffee fiend -
like me all right Tim Hortons make you
upset that you that weak-ass eysenck use
that yeah make it only in Canada what
else you got Jen all right the next one
actually would you guys even eat at this
restaurant again after this happened
yeah Tim Hortons wants a restaurant
though you're not worried about my dark
roast kazoo [ __ ] the police that's right
that's just now she [ __ ] into the actual
expresso machine Yap right path yeah
yeah I can go all right the next one is
Amy Schumer going onstage interrupting a
stand-up comics act like five minutes in
so she can do her monologue for SNL
that's not sure I don't buy that it's
true
no I mean well no she just randomly hit
him you know like bumping so what
happens is it's just in comics do this
wait did I have video of it I don't
think there's video of it okay so this
is what happened I'm sure mm-hmm
Amy Schumer comes in the guys to
understand him he's got he's got a
10-minute 12-minute set they light him
right away cuz she doesn't have time
they go oh cool they want her up they go
we'll light him right now which is a
little bigger than that's it awesome
[ __ ] stage that's what you do no big
deal get off the stage
and they it's called getting pumped it
happened to me a thousand times it's
fine you they just light you at five
minutes as opposed to 10 or 12 minutes
that's all and and that's it so he was
headlining does it make a difference if
he was headlining that's a small comedy
called I'm sure but if he was the
headliner isn't that how does it make a
little different is he headlining during
his headlining set to set this is no
that's the cure lines isn't a small club
oh it's not small Club okay same name is
Brendan's installation am i set I'm
doing some crowd work and then I'm
inside I hear everyone is a machine what
can I do ten minutes
and say what
so apparently amy also follows him on
instagram so she knows of him kinda and
that's why she called him by name to
keep scrolling down mhm mhm
all the way down that's not big deal
yeah it's fine people were upset he was
headlining was he doing an hour I don't
think so
oh my god what night is this this like a
Tuesday Thursday and Wednesday night
that means he's like maybe there ya know
Saturday oh oh no that's for her sure
there's also there's no headlining and
during the week you know there's like
it's like like tonight Brogan's that
Tommy Stewart wrote like get Rogen's the
big it was 20 minutes but he's also in
the middle like he's not the ending he's
not the Lucy headlines at the very end
come to see them at the Ike he's in the
middle there should be great comics well
that makes sense yeah that's what it's
good at pacify you guys to see what
exactly it makes it look like she was a
jerk no forever reason people emerged
since she went bad on Trump she has so
many issues now with that but ever since
she went bad Trump everyone said go
after a mission right now stealing jokes
and all that she's like hold on those
you know a lot of those riders I don't
love those riders were responsible I'd
only associate with that's their thing
and they brought these bits to me and
you know she's good people by the way I
don't know I like her I know people who
know her really well and she's a great
she's a great gal she it's a lot of [ __ ]
so this just escalate even they even
gave her a hard time about her new movie
because they were like oh you know your
hurts take your unpretty or something
like that
well like the the feminist side some of
the radical feminists are like you know
your body shaming she's like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about like she got
it she's even getting [ __ ] from that
side okay that kind of give me my mean
at least this is normal like notice that
comic doesn't have a problem with it no
he's actually happy cuz people were
talking about him like crazy now yeah
but you've noticed you guys have a
problem at all with it in general yeah
like that's just what happened yeah it's
just what happens no biggie
moving on good you know that like when
Jerry Seinfeld showed up at The Comedy
Store someone got bumped when he
randomly came there no one knew
someone's getting bumped correct like
literally when you're on stage
to get off all right before you get lit
or you right before you're going on I
don't how many people you have there
happen to mean 1 million times J ROCs
ooh Chris Rock scary sign that was here
I had it probably a year ago supposed to
go on at 9:30 and they came up like
eight two guys can go on before you man
like right cool and it was Chris Rock
and Dave Chappelle and they each did
like 45 minutes each and I went on it
like midnight there's three people in
the crowd that's what would a Chappelle
and Chris Rock and would do if it did it
if they did it like 10 minutes or 5
minutes into your act what did it's what
you I would understand yeah like what
what no this is my time tell Dave
Chappelle dawei yeah the crowd goes [ __ ]
you like yeah yeah the way I would get
off I would I yeah if they're like hey
you know dave says trying to honor like
oh cool I'll go tomorrow if I'm there
and back and they come to me a go dinner
on stage I would go yes you can
right now Brian count at 51 of course I
go yeah you know why he's just too
famous no they're saying if you're on
stage if you're doing that you're in the
act
wrap it Dave Chappelle wants to get on
right now it's not how they do it anyway
that his story I'm sorry all the respect
I don't even believe it
well this story is we got yeah I think
they let him and he kept going names
like Brendan I got another set I gotta
go thank you that if he Amy wouldn't do
that loud enough because if he could
hear that there was nobody in the
audience how about that there were six
people in the audience but the destroy
doesn't matter I know Caroline's I've
done Caroline's many many many times
yeah I know I know the room so that
doesn't make sense to me I know exactly
what he's talking about and I don't and
but also Amy's very aware to let's say
she rushed in there was like get off
this stage she's not stupid you don't
becoming me she were being stupid she
knows that's gonna get picked up
everywhere there's no way she did this
yeah sure I did this really like get off
I'm up i you do my mom on for silent
live know Airlines is a famous place by
the way okay
yeah I don't know anyway well good to
know though it's good to know I'm moving
on have you heard of something called
Yanni and Laurel yeah and I listened to
it which I heard Laurel with a deep
voice you did
who's hearing the Annie
I heard I think I heard Laurel okay
let's just do it real quick just to see
what you guys hear I know but reaches
you is here you can hear Yanni or Laurel
do what do you hear yanny
yeah oh yeah or Laurel Laurel yeah I
hear ya knee well right now you do big
changes a recent Twitter poll found that
that's so you guys all heard yeah when I
heard I know but you just feel you any
right now yeah okay let's look at the
planet key planet
I think there's our original post so
this yeah we need the original one
Laurel I'm here yeah knee yeah yeah hey
everyone turn yet I was it yeah I hear
ya knee here Yeti yeah but I heard
Laurel I heard before
no you thought you did I thought I did
do not see on II know I heard Laura no
yeah that's Yeti for sure yeah but I
heard Laurel before no you just confused
you thought no you don't know it well no
no it might be out of these speakers too
though depending on where you're hearing
it from so what the mystery they say was
solved well it's basically some in your
hair you're hearing something at a lower
tone lower frequency and some people can
hear higher frequencies so they're
picking up that Laurel last time so it
depends on what frequency is being
played at a lower frequency okay so if
you if you adjust it and you put some
which is above it then it becomes Yanni
that's interesting people that can hear
ya nee are better at hearing overall
their scope of hearing you still you
have Daniel oh wow so everyone hear her
yeah well night why everybody would hear
Yanni at that frequency all of us
there's nobody would hear Lauren no no
yesterday I was on Senate Showtime and
they played the same thing that yeah
that's not the clip though play the real
clip because that was no less important
everyone plays being that's the original
I just heard the other one into it
wasn't alright well they would yeah but
they play played it from a repose not
the original let me look at the original
let me see if I can find if it says
original that's it tune what you just
did not that's why it has no I think it
has 14 heard that but I heard the news I
put that one to be the original great
you leaving the building
thanks for that
I'm coming to dinner tonight but that
wouldn't be would it be news that's not
the original so here's the audio clip
everyone's arguing about this isn't the
original plate anyways so we still heard
Yanni all right yeah okay so we did hear
the original clip in everyone here is
Yanni yeah Finch thing though it's weird
it's so 47% of people here Yanni and
then 53% here low pretty even yeah
what's this this is a Cambodian couple
that have a YouTube channel and they for
whatever reason they ended up eating
endangered animals and protected species
so they're getting fined now and that's
one of the animals this woman ate that's
that's a husband and wife that is
terrible what is that this is cat Ocelot
fishing cat an endangered fishing sheet
and getting injured fishing a large
audio several yards she ate a king cobra
a shark stingrays and frogs that part of
the world that's what they do in
restaurants lot now anyways you could
see all the different animals she's been
eaten is there a YouTube channel big or
something like that much in shark she
ate yeah that was a baby great white
Jesus it does doesn't it yeah what the
[ __ ] how she catching all the [ __ ] there
so there is a thing where they I'll show
you the video of her eating a snake real
quick giant a giant Cobra and it might
be a protected species because that's
what was earlier
that's pretty much it I grew up eating
it but you know picking these even in
her country you're not supposed to be
doing with endangered species and
protected species but doesn't YouTube
just pull her video thumb no I guess
they didn't realize it but now after
they investigated yeah so she's screwed
now but she's saying she buys it from
like a local farm that sells these
things so the farm is probably gonna be
in trouble
instead of her so she says she's not
really killing him herself dude I'm
sorry but on the right scroll down says
uber driver asked pastor for a [ __ ]
in creepy text after dropping him off
yeah scary what to say
uber pastor is this one of yours chin or
not all right let me read it a new
repressor has claimed his driver
allegedly sent him a creepy text asking
for oral sex I'll drop him off
alright 33 this is in Perth Australia
shot at the Perth what's the text keep
going down
Oh after he got home he lies you
received a lewd message sent through
uber app which said if you like giving
[ __ ] with their mobile phone number
attached Jordan who is openly that's all
I said yeah I guess so
thanks for the ride oh here it is if you
like giving [ __ ] then set the number
all right well it's not that creepy his
face looks creepy that's all that's the
driver yeah that's weird as [ __ ] that's
the creepiest thing is his face the tax
stuff you like in [ __ ] here's my
number I mean it's not like in the car
he was like hey man here's I'm gonna
suck this dick this definitely shouldn't
make the news yeah what the site is a
scroll down mmm it says it says deaf man
who changed deaf man who changed mind
about kill himself dies after
accidentally touching the live wires
terrible stories here so I keep going
all right the next one is it looks funny
but it's obviously terrible there was
this crazy pack of wiener dogs that
ended up mauling a woman I [ __ ] knew
it man and if this is in Miami that's
the woman by the way but uh let's go
back the dogs here
and that dog he's a grandmother I think
we looked in man well there's a pack of
unpack look at this looks [ __ ] manic
standard Ocalan and Terrier mixes and
one Porter College Oh Oklahoma from a
attacked her Wow
and they said that the leg length of the
dogs none of them were bigger than an
adult man's hands then they killed this
lady they yeah but those dogs I bite him
[ __ ] hold on yeah not really they
were infested with ticks
Faline I fell down they were probably
hungry and they were hunting today was
durable way to go man so I might even
thick dogs what the [ __ ] I thought those
fake news too and I weren't even doc
ones they were probably just like these
made the Miami Herald it's a terrible
story like in Tuffy I wouldn't set
wiener dogs they would make it different
right the wiener dogs is what makes it I
thought they're aware dogs hair probably
Terrier mixes winter wiener dogs ain't
she gonna run away or nothing they say
like where it was that with the collar
in the yard outside of her house and
they said that the dogs were living in a
nearby like seventh one was about three
years old was possibly the facts mother
the rest it's a very suspicious story
she definitely probably died though did
she like some I like Maori or something
like that
she's in Oklahoma does she named
American african-american a mix of Asian
Spanish okay does she's Spanish Garcia's
your last name it
just it's because there's wiener dogs I
just it's terrible man
present such a dick am ia dick I said
nothing I'm gonna get to the bottom of
this story so to figure out man it's
it's these weird dogs take out a Crone
human easy it is to get away from wiener
dogs
well you just grab the [ __ ] noses and
kill them
little [ __ ] in or just start kicking
them I feel like I don't know but I feel
like she has big calves and stuff so
start kicking them [ __ ] lose my life
here got your picture yeah
it's an awkward picture so that's just
an organic sure just don't think the
wiener dog I think I'm sorry the
lighting another go to the next right
now I'm sure you guys wanna do bog to
canola and Canelo Alvarez announces he's
doing or he has signed to do a
year-round anti-doping testing with vada
voluntary yeah at least I think it's the
light yes I guess we not supposed to
laugh you laugh I think we're laughing
it was tough that nose was the nose was
substantial we all have characteristics
it's ah it's the way she went out
that's God's like really I would like to
see those dogs I bet you those dogs are
they got some pit bull on them I you
know I don't buy the terrier there but
they're making it sound like these
little dogs a 40-pound pit bull mix can
[ __ ] you
I'll get you six wiener dogs I have a
hard time believe they were nice I'll
kick the [ __ ] out of dachshunds but you
just stomp on them yeah but then saying
that all the dogs all the dogs had legs
shorter those he'll be legs back to work
man oh [ __ ] feel bad for those of course
you do that's where you're laughing is
there no it's just the now the things
around it all right come on Alvarez
announces he assignment to do it
year-round anti-doping testing was about
it all right in your heart of hearts do
you think he was doping yeah the Mexican
fans are all wearing triple G hats no I
didn't tell you that a lot of a lot more
and triple G somebody tell me that
they're all worried when they when they
fought well Mexico like Tripp G cos
makes him fine style but he's definitely
not bigger than Cannella well they also
don't like people to take steroids
they're like what the [ __ ] you know who
told you that
that's what this one that doesn't know
the game now somebody who knew the games
I'm talking about I mean could triple G
make sums like triple G stop his mixing
he's dead there no one's like tester
steroids triple G fan now no another one
she's very pretty she's so hot
talk incredibly hot so this Tommy or
Tommy Lehren she recently said is a
quote you don't you don't just come into
this country with low skills low
education not understanding the language
and come into our country because
someone says it makes them feel nice so
a genealogist went into her history
cheers that what didn't
is based on mm-hmm what kind of is oh
yeah yeah it is and I think she's right
in that the she goes she but this is she
oh these people need to understand that
it's a privilege to be an American
it's a privilege that you work towards
it's not a right that's true that's how
the problem here must work so she was
saying about people that don't speak the
language and you know so a genealogist
went into her family history and then
she tried to prove her wrong by saying
her Tomi's or Tommy's history shows that
her three generations prior
great-grandmother had been here for 41
years and still spoke German her second
great-grandmother had been here for ten
years spoke no English at all and her
great-grandfather in 1895 okay alright
it just doesn't take away from the fact
that what she's saying is that if you
bring immigrants in who are low-skilled
low education and don't speak the
language they're gonna have a tough time
assimilating and somebody's gonna have
to ultimately pay for that and that's
been the crux of immigration so a lot of
people say bring immigrants and bring
but it would be better if we brought in
highly-skilled immigrants and put our
focus on people who are highly skilled
educated and who contribute to the
economy so there's an argument to be
made there it doesn't mean that when you
say that you're just a racist and so the
problem of the way with the way we
debate in this country is is you say one
thing because you have a point of view
on on and what's that's not terrible to
say you know you want you want you want
people in here who have an education
stuff it doesn't mean that people who
don't have education don't contribute
but I or they don't work hard but but
but it all breaks down if we just start
drawing these lines oh you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] we're gonna burn you now on
because your grandmother in 1895 all
right I guess it doesn't take away from
the fact that there's a problem and a
lot of people who follow this a lot
closer more closely than I do and all of
us we'll talk about that and talk about
the fact that this country pays a large
price financially for low-skilled
migrant work workers coming
and she also mentioned that like she's
talking more about illegal immigrants
and then this proves this is tommy's
Park she said this proves that you know
she was just trying to get at her
because her relatives got in here
legally yeah so that the illegal
immigration is something we do pay for
it's expensive and it does have
consequences
illegal immigration borders are
reasonable that's not a terrible thing
to say right we all have borders to our
house to our body and a country to find
itself on its borders so if you just
have completely open borders you can
understand how people would be like that
doesn't make a lot of sense yes yes you
have compassion for people who are
coming over because they have a shitty
time at home or it's desperate of course
you do
but you also have to kind of wait things
like justice in the law so legal
immigration yeah illegal immigration is
illegal because it's breaking the law
if you're not gonna have laws at all
then get rid of borders go ahead I don't
think that would work there I don't
think that's the answer either
so just because people start talking
that way and then they're branded racist
or they're branded xenophobic or
whatever it's just not helpful to the
problem solve the problem not the person
what does your chin just one last one
announcement from the UFC saying that
they're going to Russia and that's going
to be the khabib kind of horrified right
mix a little suspect that's a fun you
see fight night yeah that's why it's a
little weird uh is it a feeler are they
trying to like work out the kinks
I still think Conor to be fight in
September I wonder if it's a feeler I
wonder if it's like let's lay the get
lay of the land
let's get work out the kinks so that we
can have the big show in Russia right No
well cuz you wouldn't go back to twice
in a year so soon yeah something's gonna
go on there for sure
yeah finite though that's why it's a
little weird I know well maybe that's a
cover for the big just to see if people
are digging until until they figure it
out well though I mean the Russian
audience the it's they're an khabib
pretty big in Russia the questioners
will add Amir Putin be there
I'm sure has he ever got any nice about
Dana by the way did you see that fight
that Loma fight with that gallon arse
yeah and Linares is outstanding world
champion you and the watch to watch and
triple G whose small I mean I'm sorry uh
let me think it was smaller I mean he uh
it's it's incredible [ __ ] incredible
we didn't talk about the fights did you
talk about our beloved elf and finally
kid are you yeah what's Thursday good
fight ratings so the projected 85,000
pay-per-view place Wow won some 10 years
oh my god holy [ __ ] what happens if it
was so bad I didn't illegally stream it
Jesus what happens if cyborg fights noon
a good fight good fight yeah good fight
good fight man
maybe her toughest fight oh yeah nose
nose brother yes stand up coming up the
end of the month I have I have Minnesota
House of comedy when either I'm there
May 11th I mean May 31st
June 1 to 2 then I met goodnights North
Carolina get your tickets at good nights
June 7 8 & 9 and then Hawaii for a
little vacay where hopefully my legs
will clear up I don't look like a red
spotted I read if I don't then shooting
special in July July 20th 20th 20th I
already sold out thank you everybody so
we don't need a third show Thursday just
just as a warm-up tie y'all I'll let you
know if those tickets go on sale find
out I'll probably only become if you
shoot on Friday and Saturday yeah just
Friday oh just Friday she shows Friday
okay though I'm gonna have to come up
Thursday yeah yeah we'll just make it
make the weekend well no I'll go home
Saturday morning it's gonna be fun
Saturday I don't know what that means
yeah you don't I was just in Chicago you
want to get right back to LA I'm the
same way dude yeah
I could have stayed in New York an extra
David throw the same yeah uh were the
[ __ ] I gonna be I'm in Houston June
22nd to 23rd you stand profit joke
tickets to fat cake calm boom that's it
brother glad you're back man
you said glad I'm black I'm glad you're
black I'm I'm glad you're black and back
black him back black and back glad to be
here it's fantastic
it's amazing welcome back to LA good to
see you boys this is a fine kid we're
out